history made on capitol hill today when  the senate voted to confirm judge  katanji brown jackson to the u.s supreme  court the vote was bipartisan three  republicans voting yes with the  democrats president biden and his  nominee watched the big moment together  from the white house and tomorrow  they're expected to hold a ceremony to  celebrate  nevada representative dina titus saying  the confirmation was quote historic well  deserved and a welcome addition to the  supreme court senator jackie rosen also  weighing in saying quote this will bring  a unique perspective to the nation's  highest court and i'm confident she will  be an exceptional justice